McDonagh [ __ ]
Victor mix the three but they were
trying to run the bases up the
three-point line that's a heck of a shot
fourth we go yeah hold a deep bow ties
it
that was the two-point shot he had he
also hit the three to tie it
they've got Tucker hanging out the
corner and now Hart run off the three
pointer part another three
Puckett's have the lead Alabama
please Alabama's it's really paying a
lot of attention to me that's not this
I lost it
who else he could be able to make the
next play you can see right there
underneath coming what underneath you'll
see all of a sudden that ball come freed
because hard got his hands on it what
underneath you'll see all of a sudden
that ball come freed because hard and
got his hands on it she's just never got
anything out of Oladipo
a long three
[Applause]
I'm a nice job and you said Victor pop
three guess him set the screen
Simone's Invictus he gets right there
and they've got eNOS who's got six eight
long arms trying to get there Victor
this he gets right there and they've got
eNOS who's got six eight long